A single nucleotide variation, or SNV, that changes
an amino acid to a stop code on like
this, is called a nonsense mutation. Nonsense because
it makes nonsense after this, there's nothing left. It
stops translation. A single nucleotide variation, or SNV.
That changes an amino acid to a different kind
of amino acid is referred to as a
missence mutation. It's also referred to as a non
synonymous mutation. And an s and v that
doesn't change the amino acid sequence at all from
the original sequence, is called a silent or
synonymous mutation. Now, silent mutations can accumulate because there's
really no selection pressure on them. And they
don't detrimentally affect the overall protein product. So one
of the most common kinds of SNVs we
find are silent mutation SNVs, where someone may code
for a valine using a GTA, and someone
else would code for valine using a GTG. Because
the overall protein is unchanged, there's no direct selection
pressure that can happen on the protein. It would
be completely random which of these alleles would
fluctuate in the gene pool. Now missense mutations could
be advantageous or detrimental. It depends entirely on which
amino acid is replaced and what it's replaced with.
Remember, structure is function. And in this case, it
all depends on what the structure of the amino acid
we're coming from and the structure of the amino
acid we're going to. And then we have nonsense mutations
which are almost. Always detrimental, because they're going to
shorten a protein sequence. Once a nonsense mutation has been
induced, everything past that mutation is not going to be
translated. Take a look at this long sequence right here.
I've given you two mutant versions. They both
have nonsense mutations. At TGA here, or UGA
in the genetic code. And TAG here or UAG it would be. Both are stop codons.
I want you to tell me which of these two nonsense mutations is going to be more
severe, and then I want you to tell me why in this text box right here.